merci d'être là pour cette édition
spéciale la suite des résultats du
deuxième tour en bourgogne en direct sur
france 3 avec les deux invités françois
rebsamen sénateur-maire socialiste
prévue hier soir
bonjour pour l'heure si d'être là pour
votre première réaction
disons bien sûr mais aussi le contexte
national analyser avec vous et puis
certains observateurs pensent que votre
agenda se remplir avec un ministère lors
du remaniement pour l'ump alain suguenot
bonjour vous êtes député maire de beaune
bien sûr nous aurons à refaire retrouver
qui restent tout à l'heure lucie r élu
hier soir et puis en direct du creusot
nous évoquerons la situation de
montceau-les-mines où marie claude
jarrot a remporté la ville face au
sortant didier mathus nous rejoindront
en courant de cette émission le député
socialiste laurent grandguillaume et
patrice joly le président ps du conseil
général de la nièvre pour les résultats
elle a besoin est toujours avec nous et
puis pour analyser les chiffres et
lilian melet et eric schimdt connu
revenant notamment sur une victoire de
la droite en bourgogne
commençons donc par montceau les mines
après 19 ans de mandat didier mathus
battu accuse le coup marie claude jarrot
l'emportent avec près de 20 points
d'avance marie claude jarrot dont le
père andré est maire de la ville pendant
20 ans sa campagne de terrain lui a
permis de prendre le dessus
reportage de michel ginot et orrit
desaunay 19 heures permanence de marie
claude jarrot les bonnes nouvelles
affluent de tous les bureaux de vote
assis sous le portrait de son père andré
jarrot maire de montceau de 65 à 80 6 la
candidate ump commencent à y croire très
fort dans le premier bureau de l'hôtel
de ville didier mathus avait trois voix
d'avancé au premier tour
ici aussi il va être devancé par son
adversaire
vers 20 heures le résultats provisoires
du scrutin suscite la première explosion
de joie chez les supporters de marie
claude jarrot
désormais plus personne dans chaque camp
ne doute du résultat final et surtout
pas la candidate qui arrive alors à
l'amérique dans une ambiance survoltée
ma première pensée va à mon père à qui
on de gaza et puis ma seconde penser
c'est pour dire merci merci au mont se
lier à nouveau ses liens qu'ils ont fait
confiance merci à mes colistiers et puis
il faut que tout le monde sache que je
serai le maire la maire de toul et
montbéliard et de toutes les montées
viennent dans une autre pièce
didier mathus attend les chiffres
définitifs pour aller proclamer les
résultats
puis il rejoint la salle entouré par ses
proches des lois après 19 ans de mandat
une page vient de se tourner pour didier
matisse au second tour l'abstention a
reculé à 39% mais cela ne lui a pas
profité
il ya manifestement eu une mobilisation
qui a plus profité à la droite
la gauche et surtout ce qui est plus
spectaculaire encore c'est un transfert
massif de voix du front national de
verve la candidate ump
quand on regarde les premiers chiffres
c'est ce qui nous frappe le plus c'est
que le front national perd pratiquement
la moitié des électeurs qui se
retrouvent sur la candidate de l'ump
vraisemblement il faut qu' il ya une
forme de mise en cause personnelle aussi
sûrement donc j'en tirerai les
conséquences
après quelques heures ou quelques jours
de réflexion
les deux candidats échanges alors
quelques mots sur la date du conseil
municipal le prochain maire de montceau
s'appellera deux nouveaux jarreau et
nous rejoignons marie claude jarrot en
direct du gros france 3 bourgogne mieux
du creusot pour cette victoire
première question à vous l'emportez de
10 points sur didier mathus première
chose comment de vous fêter cette
victoire marie claude jarrot et écoutez
j'ai fêté la victoire avec les mancelles
yen et les montcelliens à la dans la
salle du centre nautique
il n'en voulait bonjour marie claude
jarrot vous avez mené nice où l'avait
souhaité sans étiquette en même temps on
sait que vous êtes conseiller régional
ump on situe dans un contexte de vague
bleue et vous l'emportez de votre point
de vue c'est une victoire de la droite
contre un maire socialiste ou pas ce
n'est pas une victoire de la droite
contre un maire socialiste
c'est une victoire des monts ces lianes
et démons ses liens sur un projet ils
ont adhéré à mon projet et nous avons et
c'est une victoire de 2 de rassemblement
je vous rappelle est gelé je lui dit
hier soir je conduisais une liste de
rassemblement de compétences de volonté
pour leur ville alors messieurs c'est la
différence alors qu'est ce qui fait la
différence madame charbon contre un
maire est soufflé amer qui tourne voyait
plus dans les quartiers est amer qui n'a
pas su convaincre sur son bilan
est ce que le contexte national a joué
néanmoins le contexte national de
sanction de la politique gouvernementale
et national est-ce que vous l'auriez
emporté sans ce contexte
je crois que oui je crois que oui parce
que aucunement dans mon projet j'avais
des éléments liés au contexte national
aucunement alors que alors que le maire
sortant a valorisé le contexte national
dans son bilan
donc moi je souhaitais je peux
m'exprimer ainsi faire du local parce
que pendant six ans lorsque j'étais élu
d'opposition à montceau et bien j'ai
travaillé à ce projet au service des
monstres vienne et vivons célia et je
vous dis bien je crois je crois
sincèrement que je l'autre que nous
l'aurions emporté parce que je n'ai pas
en porter seul j'avais une liste de gens
formidables extrêmement compétents
extrêmement impliqué dans toutes les
parties de la ville et je crois que même
si le contexte national avait été moins
favorable
je leur ai emporté se doter merci
m'avait claude jarrot d'abord et en
direct de du creusot pour analyser cette
victoire donc à montceau-les-mines face
à didier mathus elle a besoin voyons
avec vous les villes dont la tendance
politique change donc à l'issue de ce
second tour
oui on commence avec louhans et un bref
passage pour le ps la sortante monique
bonin est battu par frédéric bouchet qui
arrive en tête avec plus de 45% des
suffrages
un cunni même scénario la ville
remportées par la gauche en 2008
rebascule le sortant jean luc delpeuch
et battu henry bonnion devient maire de
la ville à tournus là encore lourde
défaite de la gauche le maire sortant
jean legros a perd son siège ses leçons
triste claude roche qui remporte le
scrutin à saint marcel une page se
tourne également la ville le passe à
droite raymond un mur d'un devance le
maire sortant jean noël despocq de près
de 500 voix d'un lien de cette fois la
droite reprend la ville de sens avec le
retour de l' ump marie louise fort elle
avait dirigé la ville de 2001 à 2008
elle est réélu avec plus de 51% des
suffrages tonnerre bascule également
pascal lenoir est battu de 49 voix par
la liste dvd menée par dominique aguilar
en côte-d'or jean-françois cour fait
tomber la ville de conduire dans
l'escarcelle de l'ump de la droite la
candidat a profité d'une division de la
gauche pour s'imposer haut la main ce
mur reste à droite mais change de mer la
centriste catherine sadon l'emportent
avec une large avance sur le sortant
philippe aiguilles ou non et puis on
termine avec la nièvre la gauche perd
varennes vauzelles la bastion communiste
depuis 1946 isabelle bonicel est élu
avec 26 voix d'avancé
enfin reste nos verres fief socialiste
depuis 43 ans à la préfecture de la
nièvre est tombée dans les mains de
denis thuriau ancien socialiste à la
tête d'une liste sans étiquette
denis thuriau qui avait fait alliance
avec la droite entre les deux tours
françois rebsamen joaillier pendant la
numération de ces résultats vous dire
c'est bon alors jetez plus la coupe est
pleine
j'étais là au premier soir du premier
tour pour analyser cette vague bleue
dont tout le monde parle il n'y a pas eu
d'ailleurs sans tendance pour le
deuxième tour
non non non il n'y a pas eu une
inversion de tendance il ya eu
confirmation de du message que les
françaises et les français voulaient
adressé à travers l'élection municipale
aux responsables politiques nationaux
président de la république et au
gouvernement
c'est clair 18 en bourgogne perdu plus
de 150 en france de plus de 9000
habitants
vous vous attendiez quand même à une
telle ampleur de ce message est-ce que
je m'attendais à ce que la vague sont
aussi fortes
non pour répondre franchement non je
m'attendais du premier tour on avait
compris quand même mais je m'attendais
pas non plus à comment vous dire un
ressort qui aurait fait que les gens
seraient sortis spontanément pour nom
donc donc voilà c'est plus grosse
défaite du parti socialiste de l'après
guerre j'ai des choses que clairement on
avait déjà eu une énorme défaite aux
législatives en 93
on avait eu une énorme défaite aux
présidentielles en 2002
une énorme défaite aux municipales voilà
c'est comme ça il faut il faut savoir
faut savoir résister repartir et le
faire dans l'intérêt du pays
quels que soient les résultats l étang
sinon c'est le début de la reconquête
avec des symboles forts 1 comme nevers
vert que je connais bien donc
varennes vauzelles cour des comptes
c'est une hécatombe qui hélas était
prévisible on le disait au soir du
premier tour
c'est une confirmation et
d'amplification vous surplus je pense
que nos concitoyens ne veulent plus
aujourd'hui que ce gouvernement je vais
dire avec mon voisin mais peut-être même
plus du parti socialiste parce que ils
ont compris que le message il ya 24 mois
on n'est pas tout à fait celui qui était
prévu dans les seconds campagne est
aujourd'hui effectivement c'est une
reconquête vizir soir ça me rappelle
1983 je suis un pur produit de cette
génération là les trentenaires de
l'époque je pense qu en tous les cas les
échéances sont ainsi fait pour que les
choses risquent de changer d'une manière
assez importante européenne demain pour
se cherchent toutes à particulier les
sénatoriales à l'automne les élections
régionales et cantonales l'an prochain
le physionomie politique de la france et
la bourgogne prend toute sa part et la
côte d'or aux particuliers va beaucoup
changer
comment réagit le responsable de l'ump
quand il entend quelqu'un comme marie
claude jarrot qui dit moi je me suis pas
alors quel conseiller régional ump
quelle c'est le cas pour quand même un
certain nombre de gens dans votre camp
pendant ses dépens dans ces élections
la nouvelle c'est le cas alors le seul
cas nos verts parce que nous l'a
carrément la droite s'est effacée donc
je pourrais dire la même chose des coups
de feu sur le cac sport soit bonne ils
peuvent acheter une vague
je crois que cette vague là il est
expliqué bien évidemment par le désamour
des français par rapport au dossier mais
également par les efforts qui sont les
nôtres depuis 22 mois quoique on peut
tout dire de jean françois copé prem's
et que le travail est fait et y compris
aux condors ou le fait alors d'une
manière peu discrète mais ce cortège que
les premiers résultats sont là et je
crois quand on regarde l'ensemble des
candidats qu'ils soient revues sur
chacun va dire que c'est sur son bilan
ou du moins sa campagne
il n'empêche qu'il ya aujourd'hui une
vraie vague à des amours total la gauche
a perdu ses élections et en perdra bien
d'autres encore
françois rebsamen ont parlé tout à
l'heure de la réponse que doit apporter
sans doute l'exécutif mais alain
suguenot vous à la vision sénatoriales
ça va compliquer sérieusement la votre
tâche de ceux sur les sénatoriales se
traduisent les élections municipales et
les amplifie même donc il y aura
sûrement une élection très difficile au
sénat
j'ai pris le temps de faire les comptes
de regarder en face comment en france
par exemple je vais quand même dire
alain suguenot un peu de modestie
un peu de modestie d'abord il y a
plusieurs phénomènes qui sont
inquiétants pour les partis républicains
il y a un côté stablement une montée du
front national
hier j'ai que vous le vouliez ou lait
pas à la une une forme de rejet des
partis politiques installés là nous
sommes au pouvoir nous le payons vous
aurez l'occasion de vous en apercevoir
vous aussi et donc voilà mais je veux
pas minorer aujourd'hui notre défaite
en disant cela j'étais promis à la
reconnaître ici clairement donc de ce
côté là il n'y a pas de ya pas de
problème mais quand même attention on
est au bout de deux ans les deux ans les
plus durs ont été faits par ce
gouvernement parce président les
premiers résultats sont là ils vont
venir et vont venir qui sont déjà venus
au dernier trimestre ils sont là pour ce
trimestre et donc nous aurons à
l'expliquer sûrement à expliquer
beaucoup mieux sur ces clercs à dire ce
qu'on fait à dire on va où le pays va
voilà donc vous avez subi avec nicolas
sarkozy
une défaite et qu'attente vous avez
aujourd'hui une victoire aux municipales
qui est très net je ne
le nie pas à nous d'en tirer les leçons
il a excusé avait les moyens il est rare
celle des 3 2 en 2000 en 2008 vous avez
perdu aussi une centaine de villes à
l'époque d'ailleurs les bouder gagner
souvent à ces élections
donc voilà pour autant je pourrais dire
paris-lyon des grandes villes lille
reste à gauche
montée du front national dans tout le
sud de la france
problème inquiétant les européennes le
montreront je le crains
et donc j'espère que les barques et se
félicite extraordinaire quand il est uni
serait jamais c'est ça ne se dément pas
dit que nous allions damehame guichard à
dire que moi je gagne face à ces mêmes
suspects
c'est là que je voulais revenir je
venais pas là pour commenter les
résultats qui fâchent et victoire votre
victoire hier soir 1 à dijon annonce a
d'ailleurs sur les réseaux sociaux
avant même l'annoncé officielle en
mairie devant vos supporters nous étions
à vos côtés grâce à christophe taris et
romain yvos il est 21h 45 quand françois
rebsamen arrive pour annoncer sa
réélection devant ses sympathisants
le maire soulager proclame les résultats
et sa victoire avec près de 53 % des
voix
il est reconduit pour un troisième
mandat sans vrai suspense la fin d'une
campagne mais difficile que prévu
la ville de
le deuxième tour n'aura pas plus
mobilisé les électeurs près de 40%
d'abstentions la droite et allahou père
voulait les convaincre il réalise l'un
des moins bons scores sur la ville la
bataille était trop dur un contexte
déjeuner qui est particulier quand
j'obtiens effectivement le score c'était
décevant céder ses droits ce que j'ai pu
en 2008 aussi un joli port joli par la
défaite je ne vais pas aussi les
enseignements qu'on a pu en tirer
derrière dijon s'endort ce soir avec un
maire réélu et peut-être bientôt un
ministre dans ce discours françois
rebsamen à critiquer les technocrates
parisiens et leur absence de social le
remaniement est bien déjà dans les têtes
je me pose aussi des questions je
l'avais dit pendant la campagne
je ne demande rien je peux vivre change
est je verrai si j'ai des propositions
qui me sont adressées tel n'est pas le
cas pour la fin du débat en tout cas
jusqu'à demain nous sommes restés là
donc vous et votre but vous vous posiez
des questions hier soir france en
allemagne à vis des réponses je me
posais des questions je faisais surtout
un constat je vais me répéter cette
cette politique qui celle qui est menée
par la public par le gouvernement
c'est invraisemblable de ne pas donner
le change donc j'attends que ce
changement soit donnée chacun le sait
vous êtes un ami de françois hollande
est ce que vous l'avez eue au téléphone
ce match ici je suis ami avec les
discussions que j'ai eues avec lui
regarde
lui est mort après des discussions
politiques discussions politiques
mais c'est entre nous ce genre de choses
mais ce que je dis là je les guide je le
dis publiquement
voilà je pense qu'il faut il faut donner
un sens à l'action quand même toujours
toujours leur ai dit ceci vous savez
elle est difficile pour notre pays
la droite elle c'est dans un état
catastrophique avec des déficits
abyssaux
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'ils ont été
battus et nous on à l'effort de
redressement à faire mais quand on fait
l'effort de redressement à coordonnent
pas l'explication est bien il ya un
problème et le problème on le voit de
manière éclatante à traverser des fêtes
ça ou lisier déjà il ya plus d'un an
quand françois hollande est venu à dijon
vous dis exactement la même de
l'extérieur on a le sentiment finalement
qu'en dépit des avertissements d'un
certain nombre de grands élus et vous il
ya eu d'autres jean gérard collomb à
lyon par exemple a déjà dit à peu près
la même chose et on a le sentiment
finalement que les gens qui sont à paris
ont pas vraiment pris la mesure de sa
comme s'il y avait et d'ailleurs on a
senti dans les mines fronde des élus
nous on est en contact avec beaucoup de
maires socialistes qui était en grande
difficulté qui était très en colère
après les ministres pendant pendant
cette campagne il ya quoi il ya une
vraie coupure entre le gouvernement et
les élus de terrain aujourd'hui au parti
socialiste qui je pense qu'il ya une
difficulté aujourd'hui de perception du
gouvernement sortant à l'appeler comme
ça puisque je pense que premier ministre
pas tardé avec sa démission par la
public et donc ça ne devrait pas tarder
je pense
et donc si tel est le cas la vérité ce
qui a eu de la part
des élus n'ont pas une forme d une
incompréhension non pas vis-à-vis de la
politique j'en ai déjà dit tout le monde
fait les efforts qu'il faut faire pour à
la cpi il faut lutter contre les
déficits mais il faut le faire dans la
justice sociale il faut l'expliquer et
donc les élus ont bien perçu
on peut s'y faire il y à des fins qui
sont dus à l'usure
quand on est maire pendant 20 ans et
comptait encore être maire c'est des
fois difficile on n'a plus l'énergie du
début mais c'est difficile pour des élus
qui n'avait pas démérité
aucun n'avait démérité mais pas certain
mais on va dire les choses comme ça et
donc pour cela c'est c'est difficile
parce que parce qu'il trouve que c'est
injuste on retrouve toujours que c'est
injuste quand on ne se sent pas
directement le seul responsable de la
défaite est donc ça il faudra que je le
gère au groupe socialiste du sénat
demain le drame avec françois rebsamen
c'est qu'on a l'impression qui sait
encore rien passé dimanche
comme la semaine dernière il est élu wii
n'est pas très bien et lui non plus 52
portes ce lundi jour dans le contexte
qu'on connaît alors qu'effectivement on
est dans la proximité directe du
président alric
c'est aussi une traque pour le président
de république on a changé peut-être de
gouvernement peut-être on parlait encore
tout à l'heure de l'héritage de this
maintenant depuis deux ans les
situations et dix fois plus grave
aujourd'hui quand on regarde
effectivement les fondamentaux le
chômage n'a cessé de progresser on a dit
qu'on allait inverser la courbe donc
plus personne n'y croit
on va les français ne veulent plus de
vous c'est ça le problème c'est que ça
vous ne furent pas compris c'est vrai
qu'à l'intérieur on pourra changer les
hommes
c'est pas ça qui compte si vous changez
de politique change et que je voyais
donnez vous les moyens et du climat
mais non mais vous êtes complètement
immodeste continue entre lui-même au
bout de 24 mois de considérer que par
définition c'est de l'info de ce
qu'était avant vous que vous avez ni la
crise aujourd'hui la crise elle vous
explose en pleine figure
simplement parce qu'on ne l'avait pas
pris effectivement la mesure et que vous
n'avez certainement pas les moyens ni
les hommes de redresser la situation
le drame de la france aujourd'hui pour
ça qui m'inquiète c'est pas tellement
l'élection c'est pas tellement ce qui se
passera pour les femmes et les hommes
aujourd'hui c'est véritablement
l'alternance doit être mise en place dès
maintenant ce que je crains que quelles
que soient les modifications qui
interviennent la seule solution c'est de
changer complètement de politiques y
compris de majorité
justement c'est changer de politique
parce qu'on entend une partie de l'ailé
gauche dit il faut une autre politique
vous vous dites plutôt il faut expliquer
donner le sens est-ce que pas de
changement majeur
ça peut permettre de répondre à ce qui
s'est passé
le dimanche il ya des mots qui valent d
euros il ya des phrases qui valent tout
l'argent du monde c'est l'empathie
nécessaire vis-à-vis de ces françaises
que ces français qui aujourd'hui sont
dans la difficulté et ils sont pas la
difficulté depuis 24 mois ils sont la
difficulté depuis précisant parce que ce
pays a mis cinq ans à retrouver son
niveau de production intérieure brute
cinq en cinq ans de gestion de nicolas
sarkozy et donc nous avons aujourd'hui
c'est de voir de maintenir le cap
je ne vais pas dire autre chose il faut
continuer à diminuer les déficits mais
il faut expliquer au niveau européen que
l'on va pas le faire à marche forcée
pour aller vers une austérité en
français et d'ailleurs quand on est
arrivés les déficits était un set et
demi 5 l'année 2012 3 4 3 aujourd'hui
nous dit on donc on les diminue
progressivement sans casser cet outil
indispensable qu'est la croissance pour
redistribuer du pouvoir d'achat pour
redonner du pouvoir d'achat et il faut
arrêter des mesures qui aujourd'hui
pénalise notamment petite retraite et je
pense et je pense à ces gens là me sont
aujourd'hui en souffrance et qu'on ne
peut pas de manifs en une semaine alors
pour mener cette politique a chassé le
choix du podium à un public et donc jeu
qu'est ce que vous souhaitez faire
partie de cette équipe pour moi je vais
je n'ai rien demandé
sûr que les propositions je l'examinerai
et tel n'est pas le cas à l'instant où
je vous parle les mêmes choix des hommes
aura un sens politique aussi j'avais
cinq sens lui ce que les plus plus que
les hommes et les femmes c'est c'est
l'orientation politique qui compte c'est
l'impulsion qui donne seule explication
qui en est donnée
c'est le change qui est portée
briscous manuel valls a oui mais pour
les entreprises en particulier on a une
de l'économie la manette valls comme
martine aubry si l'un ou l'autre
enfin l'une ou l'autre était premier
ministre je crois que martine aubry a
décliné avant qu'on lui fasse même
éventuellement une proposition donc
voilà c'est pour mettre en oeuvre la
politique que le président de la
république alizés on est dans un
quinquennat c'est quinquennat il est
entré en fonction en 2007
on a vu que la rotation était très
rapide avec un quinquennat
c'est un autre mode de relation est
premier ministre c'est c'est pas
forcément un collaborateur mais c'est
plutôt un chef d'equipe il est là
uniquement pour mettre en oeuvre la
politique décidée par courriel à
domicile seul quelle est la légitimité
populaire est est ce que la gamme
francis vals à voir la gauche a toujours
par rapport à cette description d'une
préférence ou le type de personne qui
serait la bonne place vous rêvez gallois
je ne vous répondrai pas à cette
question c'est le choix du président
public et de lui seul près que les
français vont satisfaire simplement de
changer les hommes
je pense que j'écoutais ce matin du
sirop chroniqueur il n'y en que la
gauche du parti socialiste dit faut
revenir à une politique de gauche
françois hollande a appris entre
guillemets le choix qu'ils et elles
soient raisonnables d'une politique dite
de l'offre aujourd'hui très honnêtement
ce grand écart là c'est pas un homme qui
va le changer
quel que soit le premier ministre il
sera choisi le gouvernement qui sera
derrière
il n'empêche que aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de marge de manoeuvre et je pense
que les françaises et les français l'ont
bien compris et c'est une vraie des
espérances je rejoins françois
beauchemin crois qu'il dit
qu'effectivement les gens souffrent vrai
problème c'est qu'on leur apporte aucun
aménagement à leur souffrance
aujourd'hui a pas d'espoir c'est sage
difficulté on leur a dit pendant des
indes et des années et qu'on allait
changer les choses
je rejoins un peu ce qui était dit
s'adapte pas de france nicolas sarkozy
et difficulté elle date qu'on le veuille
ou non de 1980 on a fait rêver les
français à l'époque on leur a donné en
ruine est ce qu'ils attendaient
soi-disant et aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit
qu'on a vécu dans un système qui est
dénoncée au niveau européen qui est
dansée par d'autres pays je souhaiterais
qu'on est un fraudeur en france et qu'on
aura un jour un socialiste quel courage
de dire les choses et doha m
c'est ça quand ils sont quand j'étais
bon socialiste qui compte juste un mot
pour dire les choses alain suguenot le
dernier ministre qui est voté un budget
en équilibre cet été jean pierre
fourcade en 1974
donc la responsabilité elle est au
minimum partagé avec damas françois
hollande doit s'exprimer vite
aujourd'hui oui c'est le prochain à
paris dans les prochaines heures avec
cette interrogation sur le ministère
quid de dijon 6 par ici les propositions
dont vous parliez arrive se concrétise
français j'en ai parlé tout au long de
ma campagne j'ai dit et je le redis ici
que mon souhait le plus cher c'est si la
chanter me le permet bien évidemment en
2019 d'aider à l'élection d'un
successeur à la mairie de dijon ça veut
dire que je serai là à ce moment là
merci d'avoir été avec nous sur france 3
bourgogne voyons à présent et quels sont
les autres maires qui ont retrouvé leur
fauteuil comme vous donc françois
rebsamen
c'est avec vous que l'on va faire le
détail amusant auxerre d'abord leaf erez
arrache un troisième mandat il emporte
avec 301 voix d'avancé sur le député ump
et guillaume larrivé réélection de
bernard moraine à joigny ils avaient été
emportés la mairie ont donné huit il est
réélu à papeete au coût de 49 % des
suffrages
out un troisième mandat pour rémy
rebeyrotte malgré l'alliance des listes
de droite le maire divers gauche
retrouve son fauteuil avec 52% des
suffrages au creusot quatrième mandat
pour andré billardon ps élu depuis 95
elle recueille à près de 52% des
suffrages
enfin dans l'agglomération de dijon à
gilbert menut réélu haut la main à
talant lt lt recueille 45% des suffrages
et puis à chenôve jean esmonin conserve
son siège aussi le socialiste obtient
plus de 40% des voix merci elle va nous
sonnons l'arrivée sur ce plateau de
laurent grandguillaume bonjour député
socialiste de condom prend donc la suite
de françois rebsamen veux pas parler du
contexte et de la situation
de la gauche en france et en bourgogne
particulièrement nous continuerons la
discussion avec vous dans un petit
instant la direction l'yonne tout de
suite ou auxerre reste aux mains des
socialistes ni ferrer est réélu avec 300
voix d' avance sur l'ump guillaume
larrivé avant de partir à auxerre
revenons sur ce duel serré et incertain
où la mobilisation de tous les électeurs
de la gauche a sans doute fait la
différence ambiance hier soir avec
pauline ringenbach et amélie dès 19h45
les résultats viennent de tomber
dix crs et rémy après une heure de
tension les sympathisants socialistes
laissent éclater leur joie salle
vaulabelle l'écart n'est que de 312 voix
c'est le soulagement pour le camp du
maire sortant
j'aurais beaucoup de mal à digérer s'il
avait perdu parce que les tout ce qu'il
a fait nous avons fait sur cher et je le
félicite énormément cheval et l'embrassé
voilà où on a gagné
je suis très heureux la france n'est pas
près d'arriver
les larmes coulent sur les visages
l'émotion est grande de chercher les
abstentionnistes on a pas on les a
mobilisés ont déjà sensibilisés sur
l'importance mais de ce vote
donc je suis contente aujourd'hui ça a
payé on a gagné du terrain arrive alors
sur scène ovationné par le public
si nous avons des joueurs
si je devais trop liquide et de faire
vivre cette fois c'est plus timides sur
scène sa virée instant la vie comme si j
ai pas grand chose j'ai eu peur jusqu'au
dernier moment jusqu'aux bancs pour
directeur de cabinet m'a appelé en me
disant c'est bon et bien comme tout le
monde j'ai eu les jambes qui ont flash
de l'écologie c'est une forte émotion
d'abord parce que je n'étais pas sûr de
gagner vous de deviner je pensais que ce
serait d'ailleurs poussière et que ça et
comme je disais tout à l'heure à toutes
celles et ceux qui sont là bas c'est
l'émotion qui divergent à d'abord été
une véritable aventure humaine et ce
soir elle fait conclusions un sentiment
qui n'est évidemment pas partagée par
son opposant il est 21h15 quand
guillaume larrivé vient à notre
rencontre à la préfecture
il est accueilli par andré villiers
président du conseil général un allié et
déçu par cette défaite
guillaume larrivé a plus de coup c'est
la loi très dur des urnes
il est vrai qu'il ya une volonté de
changement très puissante qui s'est
manifesté j'ai gagné près de 1200 voix
par rapport à l'élection législative de
2012 la dynamique a été de notre côté
mais elle n'a pas été en effet
suffisante pour gagner les 160 voix qui
aurait permis en effet que le destin
d'auxerre soit très différent dans les
six années qui viennent et c'est de cela
que je suis triste aujourd'hui je suis
triste pour auxerre 6740 voix pour la
droite 7052 pour la gauche jusqu'au bout
le candidat de l'ump a pu y croire mais
contrairement à la tendance nationale
auxerre restera aux mains des
socialistes est ton nom nous justement
vers auxerre ou où le maire élu hier
soir donc les différences nous attend en
duplex des studios de france 3 bourgogne
bonjour guy ferrer en quoi ce combat qui
tient plus du marché des sites semoule
dans le reportage sans quoi que tu plus
humain car notre combat parce que la
situation était difficile compte tenu du
contexte national et j'avais compris au
banc où j'avais tous
de valises qu'il fallait une équipe qui
soit sud est qui est envie de se battre
de se battre très fort jusqu'au l'armée
à travers le reportage que nous venons
de voir il ya sur ce cas que ce fut une
belle aventure humaine et je suis
convaincu d'ailleurs que s'il n'y avait
pas eu ce grand partage entre l'ensemble
de celles et de ceux qui m'ont soutenu
soit comme cody style soit comme
militant soit comme sympathisant es bien
sans doute que la citation et puis a
traversé différait ce bon jour il ya un
certain nombre de villes commencèrent où
on disait c'est la mobilisation qui peut
jouer de votre point de vue pourquoi
offert manifestement cette mobilisation
a joué alors que dans d'autres villes
avec des maires socialistes
hélas pas fonctionné peut-être parce que
offert je disposais da da soc qui était
particulièrement solide sur lequel il
suffisait je vais le veau suffisait
entre guillemets vous le devinez et sur
lequel il fallait prendre appui aller
au-delà de ce socle chercher les voix
qui devait permettre la victoire mais de
jour en jour que chanter que ce socle
grossiste est en quelque sorte
légalement de jour en jour n'avait
aucune certitude et donc que ce stade
que ce fut une belle aventure humaine
puisque il ya trouvé sa conclusion
réellement qui hier soir au verdict des
urnes parfois à vous savez on sait avant
le résultat de l'élection sur va gagner
sur va perdre hier soir vrai banc
jusqu'au dernier bulletin selon la
formule employée est bien le joueur
n'était pas était passé françois
rebsamen sur ce plateau il ya un instant
parler de cette vague et du fait que le
gouvernement l'exécutif n'avait
visiblement pas entendu les élus locaux
vous partager ce point de vue je partage
ce point de de vue et j'ai trouvé tout
au long de ce dernier doit d'ailleurs
qu' il était particulièrement irritant
pour nous de ne pas être écoutés de ne
pas être entendus nous sentions roger
tient des permanences régulières bas
dans les quartiers d'auxerre je sentais
bien on me parle et d'économie de parler
d'emploi reparler parfois de
désespérance de 10,6
et de tout de toute nature et on sentait
bien qu'au fond c'était un fossé qui
était en train de se creuser entre
politiques conduites au niveau national
et puis la réalité sur le sur le pire
allait les élus locaux
j'envie d'hirson devrait être la rotule
naturelle entre les citoyens qui leur
donnent mandat et puis se disent ceux
qui prennent des décisions pour leur
survie bp
merci différents en direct de fer sur
france 3 bourgogne réélus dont qui hier
à la mairie d'auxerre l'île symbole s'il
en est du deuxième tour en bourgogne
nevers aux mains des socialistes depuis
plus de 40 ans maintenant denis thuriau
avec sa liste d'union sans étiquette
mais soutenu par l'ump et l'udf a créé
la surprise
il est l'homme du deuxième tour dans la
nièvre son portrait avec qui régissent
guillon et femmes et m'a dit qu'au lit
ce matin à la une du journal local sous
la légende historique mais qui est le
tombeur du ps denis for you mais vers
soit d'origine à 47 ans il est divorcé
père de deux enfants est à recomposer
une famille avec au total quatre enfants
hier soir l'ancien militant de gauche
avocat au barreau de nevers est passé à
la barre de nevers en devenant maire
sans étiquette et passants
quarante trois ans de socialisme un
supporter du ps je suis je pense
incarner
une nouvelle envie j'ai contrairement à
ce que la liste de rassemblement de
gauche prenez en disant que été les
seuls à comprendre et de versoix
moi j'ai senti fait je suis dit si je
revenu et j'ai un attachement très
particulier pour ma vie j'ai senti que
les navires soient avait une autre
attente puisque moi aussi j'en avais une
autre alors que j'ai été avant parti
socialiste non c'est pas faire tomber
son celi s'était proposé de nouvelles
voix sa liste indépendante baptisée
nevers à venir
il l'a construit en sept mois arrivé en
deuxième position à l'issue du premier
tour hier elle s'est imposée avec plus
de 1000 voix d'avancé sur celle du maire
ps sortant florent sainte fare garnot
dans l'entre-deux-tours denis thuriau
convainc l'ump il eu délit de se rallier
à sa liste en réussissant des nids
curieux s'affirme comme un rassembleur
et ne veut plus qu'on lui parle de parts
contre à moi ce qui a été dit et je
relate ses martelé aujourd'hui sur les
télés nationales non vers bascule à
droite ne veulent absolument pas
basculer à droite il va falloir sortir
de ça parce que tant que les parties
seront comme sage pour hier que leur
chute
leur chute va continuer donc il faut
sortir de ça et faire le constat
qu'aujourd'hui les citoyens attendent
autre chose nous avons pu proposer cet
autre chose dans l'intelligence dans la
socialité maire de nevers avec aussi de
fortes chances d'être le futur président
de l'agglomération
denis curieux n'attend désormais qu'une
chose prouver qu'il est capable de gérer
une ligne de 36 ni habitants sans
appartenir à aucun clan népal en direct
sur france 3 bourgogne la nièvre où nous
sommes attendus à nevers par patrice
joly le président socialiste du conseil
général de la nièvre il est donc cette
défaite à nevers citons varennes
vauzelles garchizy également bonjour
patrick jolly c'était un choc déjà sept
défaites en neuf heures bonjour bien
évidemment c'était un choc
c'est une histoire qui tourne une page
une certaine manière on le cette défaite
là comme d'autres
repose sur de longs textes sanctionner
le gouvernement c'est clair peut-être
aussi d'une certaine manière c'est
l'envi qu'ils ont eue nombreux de nos
concitoyens sur ce département comme
ailleurs en france de tourner les pages
sur des gens qui pouvaient incarner
le système enfin c'est s'est présentée
ainsi je crois que certains ont de
droite ont été battus pour les mêmes
raisons c'est-à-dire le une demande
forte de nos concitoyens de pouvoir
intervenir dans une période qui est
difficile et lorsque les réponses sont
pas en adéquation avec ses attentes
l'envi d'essayer autre chose je crois
que c'est ça qu'il faut aussi comprendre
dans le résultat de ce vote dans ce
département comme ailleurs en france
keystone eric sicaud la nièvre donc
terre se félicitèrent mitterrandienne
c'est loin d'être fini je crois que les
socialistes dans ce département aussi en
tout cas la collectivité départementale
que j'incarne montre une véritable
capacité d'innovation de rénovation à la
fois sur les valeurs sûres les objectifs
de développement et puis également sur
les pratiques non non je ne crois pas à
franck et valeurs de gauche ont des
valeurs de solidarité des valeurs de
développement et développement durable
aussi et je le redis cette note
collectivité départementale témoigne de
cette capacité de à se rénover
denis thériault a mentionné à nouveau
dans le reportage qu'on vient de voir
son va dire sans son passé au parti
socialiste
de votre point de vue quelle position le
parti socialiste doit-il avoir avec
denis curio se rapprocher de lui ou
considérer que dans la mesure où il a
fait alliance avec l'ump du déni c'est
carrément un maire aujourd'hui
d'opposition parti socialiste moi
j'entends ce qu'il a dit il nous a
rappelé qu'il avait des valeurs qu'il
avait un engagement
il se trouve que l'agglomération de
nevers et la ville également représente
un point particulier dans ce département
que nous avons les uns et les autres à
essayer de travailler au mieux dans
l'intérêt des des nivernais est en tout
cas nécessairement au regard des
responsabilités qui seront qui seront
les siennes et qui sont les miennes
on aura nécessairement à travailler
ensemble ça me paraît indispensable je
pense qu'il faut sortir aussi d'aider
des querelles politiciennes d'avoir une
approche qui soient strictement
partisanes moi je me bats serait sur des
valeurs pour pouvoir travailler de
manière utile avec les équipes de nos
verts comme les autres d'ailleurs
sans exclusive mais en étant très
attachés effectivement à ses valeurs de
développement de développement durable
de de solidarité qui sont celles qui
font la gauche et d'attachement à notre
département que nous avons en
responsabilité d'une certaine manière
partagée
oui vous attendait maintenant une
réponse aussi j'imagine du gouvernement
et vous allez parmi cette réponse vous
demandez voir un ministère du
développement rural en quelques mots ça
vous paraît réaliste alors qu'on parle
d'un gouvernement resserré vous avez
compris le sens de notre démarche est de
dire nos territoires ruraux sont en
souffrance
ils ont besoin qu'on les donne en
matière de développement économique on
leur redonne des capacités productives
concret d'emploi également la démarche
est pas n'avoir pas à me faire du
développement durable c'est d'avoir une
vraie politique surtout de développement
rural et pâle ministère étant l'élément
un peu lisible bien évidemment qui sera
assise assez fort mais ce dont ont
besoin nos territoires c'est le
sentiment de ne pas être relégués
abandonné passer au second rang l'avenir
de la france passe peut-être par les
métropoles mais ça passe aussi par les
espaces ruraux
la france a le plus bel espace rural
d'europe à la fois sur le plan de sa
quantité d'espacé du foncier sont des
ressources naturelles ce sont aussi des
ressources humaines un cadre innovation
y avait critiqué créativité sur le
territoire il serait dommage que notre
pays se prive pour lui-même et ses pour
les territoires concernés de cet
avantage qui est un avantage
concurrentiel c'est comme ça que je
conçois pas très jolie en direct de
nevers président du conseil général de
la nièvre
peut-être justement sur ce terrain est
il des secteurs le rang guillaume qui
ont été oubliés par le gouvernement
patrick jullian en parlait les
territoires ruraux par exemple je crois
que le gouvernement n'a pas écouté n'a
pas écouté suffisamment les élus locaux
les parlementaires que nous sommes ce
n'est pas faute de l'avoir dit à
plusieurs reprises ce n'est pas tout
d'avoir fait remonter des signaux
d'alerté
comme sur la question des heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées qui avait
été supprimée qui touchait directement
au pouvoir d'achat des ouvriers des
employés et donc des catégories
populaires des classes moyennes donc ce
n'est pas faute d'avoir exprimé ses
sujets à partir du moment où on ne nous
écoute pas eh bien il ya d'abord la
résignation
en fait quelle indifférence et
l'indifférence a été l'abstention
sanctions donc je crois que face à cela
et bien
il va falloir prendre des mesures sans
doute radical des changements profonds
d'abord je pense à un changement de
gouvernement
ça va de soi deuxièmement une
réorientation de la politique parce que
les réponses ne sont pas suffisamment
apporté les résultats se font attendre
et puis enfin je crois qu si le parti
socialiste doit se poser des questions
moi je crois qu'il faut un nouvel epinay
c'est à faire en sorte que cette gauche
fragmentée se rassemblent sur le combat
des idées parce que lorsque la gauche
justement n'est plus en capacité de
mener des combats
l'idée n'est plus en capacité de porter
une espérance et bien forcément elle
recule et je crois que là il y a trois
pistes importantes à suivre et j'espère
que dans les semaines qui viennent et
dans les jours qui viennent il va y
avoir des signaux forts on sait ce qu'on
peut revenir sur la situation à dijon à
l'envers quand même très mauvais score
de la droite à dijon comment vous voulez
analyses et autres mauvais score je
n'aime pas ça mais c'est vrai que c'est
une élection c'est vrai que la chanoine
qui a pas de geste est sûre de la
campagne n'a pas été très favorable
je sais que je suis rachat entre de
l'union la preuve partout il ya union le
plus tôt possible
l'exemple de d'ailleurs et confiseurs je
crois que les joueurs de chalon sur
saône
c'est qu'il y avait quelques fois des
différences il n'empêche que soit martin
et que ce soit la pièce met d'accord
très vite une question toute bête nous y
avait des gens même si françois xavier
dugourd n'a pas souhaité aller cette
élection il y avait un certain nombre de
conseillers d'opposition qui étaient
dijonnais pourquoi est-ce que c'est
finalement un élu de salive ou un élu de
saint romain avec emmanuel bichot tous
sont venus sur dijon alors qu'il y avait
des candidats qui pouvait apparaître
comme légitime est ce que ce n'est pas
une erreur stratégique et rôle
stratégique c'est électro dj sur les
candidats ils ont décidé aussi bien
michel aoun le cardinal paix pourra dire
c'est pas une bonne idée on fait
autrement oui ça y est les investitures
il ya aussi des parlementaires donc à
vraiment déterminé le problème c'est
qu'il a des futurs c'était l'union je
pense que je reviens là dessus quand on
fait l'union se montrer dans toute la
france la guerre des races éviter le
psychodrame
quand elle est connue avec la laine
votera la dernière fois quand votre
accepte purement et simplement de
travailler avec arnaud robinet ou gagner
c'est valable dans toutes les villes de
france qui ont été promises plus de cent
cinquante cinq ans mais depuis neuf
militants je crois que cet exemple il
est parlant l'exemple de dijon doit
servir en tous les cas là
candidat au père il est candidat il est
sénateur et quand vous avez quelqu'un
qui est très volontaire c'est pas une
critique assez volontaire on savait
qu'il irait jusqu'au bout il n'y a pas
démérité cinq ans n'a pas été mauvaise
simplement je pense en effet que cette
année dans le contexte qu'on a connu il
on n'a pas forcément bénéficié à
profiter de la vague bleue qui était le
nôtre voilà ce qu'on a dit il faut dire
que la droite la question plus mauvais
score dans l'histoire de la ville de
dijon et on connaît bien la sociologie
et les évolutions aussi qui l'a dit j'en
ai donc c'est un très mauvais score pour
la droite à dijon dans un contexte
national qui lui est très favorable
donc je crois que cette campagne de
mensonges et de contrevérités sur le
bilan sur sur plein de choses
eh bien je crois à détourner les
électeurs aussi des journaux également
en direction de cette droite
républicaine et a fait monter ailleurs
le front national et à dijon notamment
et donc je crois que là bas il faut le
sont aussi pour vous même parce que j'ai
vu aussi je vous sais il faut faut
rester humble nous nous avons gagné on a
fait un bon score dans un cadre d'une
triangulaire
maintenant le travail commence pour
répondre aux attentes des habitants pour
les protéger une scie face aux effets de
la crise et puis pour ceux qui auraient
aimé contre vérités gens je crois est
joué vous posez la question françois
rebsamen à poté des aspirations
est ce qu'un jour on veut raffiner caser
le décor et la colère de dieu ou alors
lui je suis député je suis conseil
municipal parce que j'ai choisi de
m'impliquer le non cumul des mandats
avec un exécutif local c'est vrai ne pas
être adjoint donc je continue mon
engagement bien évidemment depuis le
jour où la question se posera j'y
répondrai aujourd'hui la question ne se
pose pas donc je continue à appliquer
pour dijon et dans mon mandat de
parlementaire
merci à venir spéciale en direct sur
france 3 bourgogne miron se retrouve
dans le 19/20 bien évidemment pour une
nouvelle page sur les municipales et
vous retrouvez tous les résultats sur
notre site bourgogne point france 3
point fr très bel après midi sur france
3 tout à leur honneur